se battre pour la démocratie le visage
de l'icône a sense outils sur les
t-shirts des milliers de manifestants et
manifestantes birman un mot d'ordre se
libérer de l'oppression de la junte
militaire depuis un mois et demi
les défilés se multiplient en voiture à
moto ou à pied dans tout le pays
[Applaudissements]
nous allons leur faire savoir aux
militaires à quel point nous ne sommes
pas d'accord avec eux nous ne voulons
pas d'eux nous ne les accepterons pas et
nous les détestons énormément ce n'est
pas vrai que rangoon est finie et que la
ville ne voit plus de manifestations
nous voyons encore des manifestations
ici tous les jours une arme est présente
dans les rues des grandes villes du pays
entre répression et intimidation
selon l'association d'assistance aux
prisonniers politiques
près de 250 civils ont été tués depuis
le coup d'état du 1er février des
chiffres devenu très alarmant pour
l'union européenne dans le cas de la
birmanie
nous allons prendre des sanctions contre
onze personnes impliquées dans le coup
d'état et dans la répression des
manifestants le chef de la junte
militaire dans l'oeil du cyclone des 27
ainsi que neuf des plus hauts gradés des
forces armées et le président de la
commission électorale ces derniers ont
interdiction de se rendre au sein de
l'ue et leurs avoirs européens sont
gelés des sanctions liées aux dernières
décisions de l'armée birmane qui a
décrété notamment la loi martiale dans
six cantons de l'agglomération de la
capitale économique
rangoun la junte donne le pouvoir
administratif et judiciaire de la loi
martiale au commandant régional de
rangoon afin qu'ils exercent dans ces
communes afin d'assurer la sécurité de
maintenir l'état de droit et la
tranquillité plus efficacement
l'indonésie et la malaisie membres de
l'association des nations de l'asie du
sud-est et fidèle habituellement au
principe de non-ingérence ont appelé à
une réunion de crise des dix pays de
l'asean pour discuter du dossier birman